hey this is really weird speaking of
cases Donald Trump now says he is
honored not horrified not concerned
Trump is honored that we in the United
States have by far the most coronavirus
infections in the world this is
extremely odd here is the man himself
saying it so when we have a lot of cases
I don't look at that as a bad thing I
look at that as in a certain respect as
being a good thing because it means our
testing is much better so if we were
testing a million people instead of 14
million people we would have far few
cases right so I view it as a badge of
honor this is absolutely crazy Trump
Trump talks about this as an honor he's
not really honoring the victims or their
families when he continues to just
flippantly remark about we've we've
passed the peak we figured it out we're
the best we've got the most tests the
best tests we've got all the equipment
we've got all the different stuff we're
reopening it's all great we did so well
he doesn't seem to be honoring anyone
and Trump continues to be completely
confused about testing he keeps talking
about raw numbers we've you know a
million tests 14 million tests let's
give this some serious thought because
this matters you know Trump's wacky
comment about a badge of honor from
having the most infections it's not some
is bonkers off-the-wall cuckoo for cocoa
puffs but let's use it to actually get
informed about things let's not just
dismiss it as the rantings of a lunatic
which it is but Trump's idea is we have
so many infections because we have so
much testing okay let's explore that
let's look at the numbers of the five
million global confirmed coronavirus
cases the US has about 1.6 million so
what we have in the u.s. is 32 percent
of the cases but we only have 4% of the
population so the cases are out of sync
with our population now we have more
cases than the next I think it's six
countries combined globally the case
numbers are crazy but do we have the
most cases because
we have the most testing well not really
in the sense that our testing per capita
is still only 38th in the world
so what Donald Trump is claiming doesn't
make any sense and we still are only
testing about three hundred and
seventy-five thousand people per day I
sound like a broken record I've told you
many times now we should have been at
five hundred thousand a day more than a
month ago we need to get to five
thousand and five hundred thousand a day
to eventually get to one and a half to
five million tests per day that's what
you need to really be doing significant
surveillance testing where you would say
listen regardless of symptoms if you are
65 or older you need to get go and get a
test this week okay next week if you are
between 55 and 65 go and get a test you
need one and a half to five million
tests a day to be able to start doing
that kind of surveillance testing we are
nowhere close to that even still let's
move on to the next analysis maybe most
importantly there is no doubt that case
numbers do depend on testing even if the
u.s. is only 38th per capita in testing
but deaths do not depend on testing and
when you look at deaths per capita the
United States is 12th highest in the
world in deaths per capita out of more
than 180 countries as Donald Trump often
likes to say our deaths per capita not
total deaths now okay well of course
we're number one in total deaths but
that's that's different we're talking
about deaths per capita deaths per
capita the United States is the 12th
highest out of more than 180 countries
so a lot of people have been writing to
me saying David you've got to talk about
this with Joe Rogan next time you go on
I do hope that this comes up next time I
go on and talk with Joe Rogan about it I
want to get the data out there and and
the the frustrating thing about this is
that it's shocking how many people are
making claims about cases deaths testing
without understanding that you can just
go find the data very often I will tweet
a screenshot of testing numbers per
capita deaths you know whatever right
I'll tweet it and in the responses
people are responding to thing
where it's implicit that we just don't
have access to a bunch of this data the
data is available and one of the things
that you know if I get an opportunity at
some point soon to talk with Joe Rogan
about this it's not going to be about
attacking anyone or proving anybody
wrong it's going to be to point out that
we don't have to speculate about a lot
of this stuff because we have the data
now if you want to argue there is
something missing from the data or the
data is inaccurate in some way I welcome
that discussion it seems increasingly
when we look at places like Florida that
the inaccuracies go in favor of those
who want to pretend that this is no big
deal but I welcome the opportunity to do
that I want to give a quick shout-out to
one of our sponsors VIN Chara watches
they're giving my audience 15% off your
entire order when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch maybe you don't
usually wear a watch and you've been
thinking about looking for one to
elevate your look or you've been
thinking about replacing the one you
have
check out vin chair oh it's an american
company all of their watches are built
in small batches from high-end materials
they look amazing and they look like
something you'd spend a lot of money on
but ever even Cheryl watch ranges from a
hundred and fifty to three hundred
dollars I went on their website and
picked out the Kyros in white and silver
really loved the look the combination of
the white face and the beige band really
loved this one they also sent me the
Kyros limited release gold reserve set
totally different style this one would
make a fantastic gift for a couple
people I can think of in my family any
time you see me wearing a watch on the
show I'm wearing a van share o watch go
through their collection I know you'll
find something you like and you'll get
15% off when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch